to complete our insight into the notion
of this movement and may further be
noticed that the differences themselves
are exhibited in a two-fold difference
once is a difference of content one
extreme being force reflected into
itself but the other the medium of the
manners and again as a difference of
form since one solicits and the other is
solicited the former being active and
the other passive according to the
difference of content they are
distinguished merely in principle or for
us but according to the difference of
form they are independent and in their
relation keep themselves separate and
opposed to one another the fact that the
extremes from the standpoint of both of
these sides are thus nothing in
themselves at these sides in which
they're different essences were supposed
to consist our only vanishing moments
are an immediate transition of each into
its opposite this truth becomes apparent
to consciousness in its perception of
the movement of force but for us as
remarked above something more was
apparent that is that the difference is
law differences of content and form
vanished in themselves and on the side
of form the essence of the act of
soliciting or independent side was the
same as that which on the side of
content presented itself as force driven
back into itself the side which was
passive which was solicited or for
another was from the side of form the
same as that which from the side of
content presented itself as the
universal medium of the many matters
in Section 140 Hegel is telling us that
we need to further think out some of the
implications of this bifurcation of
force into multiple forces that are in
some sort of reciprocal relation to each
other and he says that we don't look at
this in terms of form or in terms of
content as a matter of fact we not only
can look at them in either form they in
either way we need to look at them in
both ways so that we can see how they
can act up with each other and we see
that insofar as we're talking about
content we can talk about force as being
reflected into itself on the part of
either force or we can talk about it
being a medium of independent matters
and the force reflected into itself is
core relative to the force as a medium
of matters for this force over here
right and vice versa either one can take
on either position and as we've seen
these are going to be mutually implying
because the very act of being the medium
is allowed to this because this is a
medium for it as well so the two forces
are connected to each other in that way
Hegel is going to go on and you notice
that I've got this bar here he's going
to say that that these two forces when
we look at it from the site of content
are not really separate from each other
they're distinguished from each other in
principle or for us from the perspective
of the thinking conscious perceiving
understanding subject right but not in
themselves when we turn to form it's a
little bit different there we're dealing
with activity and passivity so we have
the force over here as doing the
soliciting which is an activity upon the
solicit of the passive force but at the
same time it can only solicit as we've
seen because this solicits it to solicit
so there's this endless you know chicken
egg kind of thing going on there well
which one solicited first who
pulled the gonna pursue drew right and
the answer is nobody they that's the way
it works this they are set up in this
relation to each other so that
considered from from you know this side
this is the active one and this is the
passive one considered here this is the
active ones as a passive one now Hagel
says that if we're thinking about it in
terms of form then we can say that these
are indeed independent separate forces
they are something different from each
other
not already so deeply enmeshed with each
other that we can't distinguish them so
he says the fact that the extremes from
the standpoint of both of these sides
are thus nothing in themselves that
these sides in which they're different
essences were supposed to consist are
only vanishing moments are an immediate
transition of each into its opposite so
so each of these forces in a certain way
becomes other than what it is precisely
by the action or the receptivity of the
other force this force in a certain way
becomes this force and vice versa and
this this chart here reflects the many
different ways in which this is all
happening at the same time and which
consciousness can then grasp in terms of
form or in terms of content so he goes
out and he says this truth becomes
apparent to consciousness in this
perception of the movement of force but
for us something more was apparent that
the differences as differences between
content and form differences of form
differences of content vanished in
themselves and on the site of form the
essence of the act of soliciting or
independence I was the same as that
which on the side of content presented
itself as force driven back into itself
the side which was passive so there's
not only an interplay going out here and
here these are in an interplay with
each other as well so what appears to be
active is in reality a certain way
passive what appears to be passive is at
the same time active things are more
complicated than they originally appear
so he says the side which is passive
which is solicited or for another was on
the side of form the same as that which
from the side of content presented
itself as a universal medium of the many
matters we can correlate these together
and now what we're actually going to be
doing for a little while is paying much
more attention to what's going on up
here to the side of form
from this we see that the notion of
force becomes actual through its
duplication into two forces and how it
comes to be so these two forces exist as
independent essences but their existence
is a movement of each towards the other
so that such that their being is rather
a pure positiveness or a being that is
posited by an other then as their being
really has a significance of a sheer
vanishing they do not exist as extremes
which retain for themselves something
fixed and substantial transmitting to
one another in their middle term and in
their contact a merely external property
on the contrary what they are they are
only in this middle term and in this
contact in this there is immediately
present both the repression within
itself of force or its being for self as
well as its expression force that
solicits and force that is solicited
consequently these moments are not
divided into two independent extremes
offering each other only an opposite
extreme their essence rather consists
simply and solely in this that each is
solely through the other and what each
thus is it immediately no longer is
since it is the other they have thus in
fact no substances of their own which
might support it and maintain them the
notion of force rather perceives itself
as the essence in its very actuality
force as actual exist simply and solely
in its expression which at the same time
is nothing else than a super session of
itself this actual force when thought of
is free from its expression and as being
for itself is force driven back into
itself but in fact this determinant Ness
as we have found is itself only a moment
of forces expression thus the truth of
force remains only the thought of it the
moments of its actuality they're
substances and their movements collapse
unresistingly into an undifferentiated
unity a unity which is not force driven
back into itself for this itself is only
such a moment but is notion qua notion
thus the realization of force is at the
same time the loss of reality in that
realization it has really become
something quite different that is this
universality which the understanding
knows at the outset or immediately to be
its essence and which also proves itself
to be such in the supposed reality of
force in the actual substances
now 1:41 begins with saying that when
we're analyzing the notion of the
concept of the cliff force what occurs
is a kind of duplication or a splitting
doubling and we find now that that we
have force over here and a force over
here and that both of these are existing
at least we think at the time as
independent essences independent
existences independent things that are
and we're interested in their interplay
with each other we have to watch out
from treating them as if we're looking
just now at two substances that are
arranged in a reciprocal relation to
each other
Hegel's going to try to keep us from
falling into that trap
why says their existence is a movement
of each towards the other such that
their being is a pure positiveness or a
being that is posited by another they
really just possess being for another
and whether we want to think of them as
being the solicited or soliciting forces
if we're thinking in terms of form or if
we want to think of them as being force
driven into itself or force you know
that is a passive medium accepting the
other force in terms of content we see
that both sides in fact provide that to
the other and it's difficult to say you
know which one is ontologically prior to
the other as a matter of fact we can't
say that that's what it means for them
to be reciprocal
so Hagel says that what that really
means is that neither one is substantial
in itself at least not at this point
what do we get them he says they do not
exist as extremes which retain for
themselves something fixed substantial
transmitting to one another in a middle
term just like you know if I am
affecting this book right I am one thing
this book is another thing now I you
know pop the book right it makes a sound
I turned the pages if you know I effect
it I rub truck on it you know I am I was
kind of dumb to do so I'm security the
print I didn't think the truck would
stick you get surprised by things in any
case you see that what we're talking
about here the the you know the action
or what's what's going on is the middle
term the book is one of the substances I
am the other substance and I'm doing
something to it anyone saying no it
doesn't work that way with forces there
is a middle term and that middle term is
going to turn out to be awfully
important it's gonna be where the
substantiality is going to actually
reside so he says on the contrary what
they are is only through this middle
term the force relates to the other
force through this middle term this
force relates to its opposite force
through the middle term so the question
that we want to ask is well what what is
this middle term he says in this there's
immediately both the repression within
itself of force or its being with itself
being for self as well as its expression
for sets elicits and force that is
solicited so these moments are not
divided into two independent extremes
offering each other only an opposite
extreme their essence occurs rather
simply in this each is through the other
what each is it is no longer is because
it is the other so these two extremes
are unable to support themselves except
through this motor what's that middle
term that well if we think about this I
mean we could go to the text and we will
in just a moment
what have we originally talked about in
section 136 when we started talking
about force and then started to
progressively leave out of the picture
over the last couple paragraphs think
about content
we talked about the force as having two
sides to its content the force in itself
the force as the medium what unites
those two well the forces expression it
can't it can't come out of itself into
the medium the medium can't function as
a medium for something to come into it
unless there is expression the inner
becoming outer at the same time so this
expression is what connects these forces
together that's what unites the passive
and the active on both sides so he goes
on and he says they they don't have any
substance of their own that might
support them the notion of force rather
preserves itself as the essence in its
very actuality force as actual the
notion of force as actual is this in the
expression of the force how do you know
that there's actually a force happening
because it does something because
something affects something else it
exerts some sort of I don't want to say
force it exerts some sort of power
there's a synonym there it exerts some
sort of effect it makes something and
determines something that's expression
that's externalization that is becoming
X be coming outward so he says this is
nothing else than a a super session that
is an out paper of itself a going to a
higher level in a certain way you can
say well the expression isn't really the
force itself the force itself is that
thing that's like bound up inside of
itself or is that thing over there
that's the medium but you only get those
through the expression so the expression
is really more important from a gallium
point of view he says the actual force
when thought of is free from its
expression as being for itself is force
driven back into itself but this
determinist is only a moment to forces
expression you only have force driven
back into itself because you have any
force that is expressing itself in some
other force it's a medium you only have
a force acting as a medium because you
have a force expressing itself so
without expression no force an
expression is supplying us with the
notion of force or as he's going to say
the notion as notion so he says that's
the truth of force is going to remain
the thought of it the moments in its
actuality they're substances that
movements collapse unresistingly into an
undifferentiated unity a unity which is
not force driven back into itself but
its notion qua notion the notion qua
notion has not yet developed for us as
notion it's it's you might say stuck in
its objective status it's not yet been
made subjective for us by bringing us
into it as we're gonna see happen a bit
later on but we've taken away a very
important clue about the nature force
this thing about expression space is the
realization of force the realization of
force as no longer connected with our
view on it but just force in itself
turns out to be its loss of realization
the only thing that is allowing us to
keep any hold on force itself is the
fact that we are trying to work out its
notion we are attending to its
expression he says and the realization
has become something quite different
that is its universe this universality
which the understanding knows at the
outset or immediately to be its essence
and which also proves itself to be such
in the supposed reality of force in the
actual substances so again the the
emphasis is going to be on expression
what is really happening
what is phenomenal for us what are we
taking in what is presenting itself to
us that's going to be the reality of
force that has been
the essence that's going to be as we're
moving our weight into it the
unconditioned Universal starting to show
itself
insofar as we regard the first universal
as the understandings notion in which
force is not yet for itself the second
is now forces essence as it exhibits
itself in and for itself or conversely
if we regard the first universal as the
immediate which is supposed to be an
actual object for consciousness then the
second is determined as the negative of
force that is objective to sense it is
force in the form of its true essence in
which it exists only as an object for
the understanding the first universal
would be force driven back into its self
or forces substance the second however
is the inner being of things qua inner
which is the same as the notion of force
quando ssin
in this short section number 142 which
is rather dense rather Pat Hingle is
bringing things to a naught we've seen
this happen many times before
he's going to be drawing things to a
kind of a clause only for them to open
up again you know what he's talking
about here are two different universals
there's been a transition that's taking
place throughout these previous
paragraphs he says in so far as to
regard the first Universal and as the
understandings notion in which force is
not yet for itself the second is forces
essence as it exhibits itself that's all
in and for itself so what does that mean
remember what we've got when we're
talking about being for itself is a kind
of relation a reflexive relation that
something has to itself this is
something that we see characterizing
consciousness we saw it earlier is
characterizing universals characterizing
the thing they have a relation to
themselves and force has not at that
point been brought to the point of
having this relation to itself and in
relation to its other but it's not yet
to itself and now we've made a
transition to grasping forces essence in
and for itself whenever you see that in
and for itself what we're talking about
there is the kind of status metaphysical
that characterizes something with
substantial being something that that
genuinely is at least you know they have
put in the dialectic and often turns out
not to be so in the next paragraph
Hegel's going to characterize this
another way as well so what we're
beginning with or what we had earlier is
force as an immediate actual object for
consciousness as the is that which was
presenting itself to us and you know as
we always see Hegelian immediacy always
ends up being mediated and
look at the mediations here you could go
right back to the preface and see you
know going from me
immediate to the negation of it we have
the negative of force the negation of
force they saying no it's not that as an
object for sense as something that's
perceived by the senses and we've
realized that force in its essence is
for the understanding you're not going
to be able to perceive force just
through sense certainty just through
perception we're going to see him
talking about that later on instead it
requires the work of abstraction or
imagination or doing something with the
understanding that goes beyond the
merely sensible to thee as he's going to
say later on Supra or above sensible now
that's we're going to get coalesced into
the sensible there's a lot more to be
said about that than I don't wanna ruin
the ending for you at least in this
chapter another way to think about this
is we've been looking at force as if
it's a substance and now we start to
realize that we need a more supple a
more sophisticated conception of force
so then we can get to the notion of
force as notion the notion of force as
notion is going to have to do with this
leaning in and for itself but also for
it being for consciousness just not
being for consciousness or being for the
understanding in the way that it was
over here another way of getting at this
is to talk about trying to reach the
inner being of things quite inner
beautiful formulation that he's talking
about we do have the sense quite often
many of us that there's more to reality
than just what we're seeing or sensing
or or you know what we're remembering
that there's something behind the the
appearances that we want to get at we
have this sense of that many people have
had that conception throughout time
that is what Hegel is calling the
unconditioned universal that is what we
have been in pursuit of and that is
where we are going to try to go now
through these these you know discussions
you know
and excursions sorry exhibitions and
dissertations about about force so what
we have here we have the realization
that we've made some sort of progress
Hegel's trying to chart out what that is
and now we have some new beginning
points to start with and we have a new
goal adequately conceptualized before us
the intervening of things quoi inner